the biden department of justice is
making a risky political move in arguing
and appealing the florida judge's
decision about masks on planes and if
this fails to work this could jeopardize
the ability
of the cdc and other agencies to ever
require
masking or other public health
guidelines on public transportation if
it fails so it is very politically risky
so let's back up and i'll tell you
what's going on
earlier this week a florida judge
decided
that the cdc had overstepped its
authority
with the masks on planes and genera we
call it masks on planes but it's like
masks on on mass transit regulated by
the federal government but let's call it
masks on planes the argument was cdc
overstepped its boundaries and the
argument made by the judge in her
decision
was that the cdc is allowed to put in
place guidelines for the sanitation of
airplanes and that a mask on a person
is not really about sanitation on
airplanes now you could argue well you
prevent needing to sanitize the seats if
people wear masks and they don't put
germs on the seats like it starts to
become a semantic thing but one of the
notable aspects about the decision was
that argument could have been made at
any time during the pandemic and it was
made by a judge now
with just like 10 days left until most
likely the masks would be coming off
anyway although we're not totally sure
earlier yesterday joe biden was asked
should people still be wearing masks on
planes and the republican party and
others made a big deal out of this
answer which joe biden gave
people continue to wear masks on planes
that's up to them
that's up to them saying that is a
personal decision it's an individual
decision it's not for the government to
tell people what to do
and then moments later the department of
justice has appealed the federal ruling
on the transportation mass mandate cnn
and others reporting the justice
department wednesday appealed a ruling
by a federal judge that struck down the
mask mandate for mass transportation
following a recommendation by the cdc
it is the cdc's continuing assessment
that at this time an order requiring
masking in indoor transportation
remains necessary for public health they
will monitor
they will appeal
there is a court decision that is
ultimately coming forward so let's talk
through the different aspects of this
some are focusing on
the biden administration the left hand
doesn't know what the right hand is
doing joe said it's a personal decision
and yet his doj is appealing i actually
don't think that's a that's a problem in
any way we've said before when it was
trump trying to direct the doj on what
to do we would say trump should have no
involvement with what the doj does who
it investigates what it does it should
be just up to the doj so it's a good
thing that joe biden gave us his opinion
well right now it's an individual
decision because at the time it was and
separately
as is supposed to happen at the end of
the day the cdc in consultation with the
doj have said we still want this and we
believe that legally we have a case so
the doj is appealing i don't have any
issue with that and republicans have
been saying oh it's just it's chaos joe
says one thing do you no this is
happening as it should joe biden gave
his opinion the doj is making its
decision in consultation with the cdc
and they will carry forward a legal
argument as to why the masks should
remain
which is their opinion
now what is the risk to the doj doing
this particularly when the mask mandate
may have been ending on may 3rd anyway
we don't know that for sure originally
the mask mandate was through april 18th
there was an extension through may 3rd
cases are actually rising now 25 30
percent it it's not clear whether
medically it makes sense to get rid of
masks on planes but it seemed
politically it was likely coming to an
end on may 3rd anyway
what's the risk to doing this well the
risk is imagine that the doj fights this
as full-throatedly as they can
and they don't get the masks put back on
that could then serve as really powerful
and destructive precedent in the future
imagine we get the next uh the the next
wave you know call it the whatever
whatever wave the sigma wave
and it's the more contagious than ever
it's more deadly than ever and it would
be appropriate to say masks have to be
on at airports and on planes
if this decision doesn't go the doj's
way
there may be a total inability to put in
place a mask mandate when it's like
really needed right now it's like
probably a good idea but listen maybe we
leave it up to people to decide we could
have a situation in six months and 12
months where it's like wow we we
absolutely need masks on planes
and there might be no way to get it done
because of the decision that might be
forthcoming here so that's the that's
the legal and political risk it also
would just look bad
if you know hero trump appointed 35 year
old female judge
uh prevails over garland and the doj it
just looks bad politically and so that
is the risk and we won't know for a
little bit uh what happens but that is
what's going on
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video